voilà
vous êtes magnifique vous aussi vous
êtes magnifique merci et bien sûr ces
belles paroles je vous laisse
j'aurais jamais accepté d'être enterrée
s'il savait du parti il ya des retours
en plus ça attaque les yeux les vautours
quoi mais oui bien sûr 100 emplois
permanents et s'écrit beagle et on peut
rien
espérer respirer profondément non non la
prod terre on peut pas bouger il ya un
truc n'diaye plat pour enlever la guêpe
et arrête ton cinéma c'est pas la petite
bête qui va manger la grosse
[Musique]
envie de faire pipi aussi quelques tu
crois ça fait deux heures je les fais
pas ça et je pisse moi aussi
ça y est c'est parti qu'est-ce qu'on a
ratés comme coche pour en arriver là
syngeta malaise vagal
jeunes tram évalué
comme enfin c'était clairement spécifié
sur le site que le principe du stage
j'ai payé pour ça
c'est pas une psychopathe elle est
créative et vous savez que aux états
unis il ya 304 castration parole et
femmes à la coupe et sexe de se marier
là j'étais aux toilettes
il a réussi à récupérer parce qu'il a
plu la compagnie des eaux accompagné des
élus a ramené et il s'est fait recoudre
parce qu'au peuple recoudre ouais on
peut te faire recoudre exact
par nature
je ne sont plus mobiles oui vous savez
quoi les garçons vous savez ce qu'on vit
là on est en train de se tricoter des
souvenirs des super souvenirs
bonjour messieurs
allons-y juste même si
[Musique]
vous êtes là c'est parce que vous allez
mal
[Applaudissements]
et c'est parce que vous avez envie
d'aller mieux
voilà c'est ici et happy jele beau de
merde
j'ai
fait rien les fais mon amour rien n'y a
même pas de réseau apparemment je vous
assure que mon peut fonctionner sans
vous c'est seulement quatre jours on va
positiver
on est bien là
non ça va ça va à ces [ __ ] si
c'est une coupe de golf et un rôti
d'agneau mais d'accueillir vannes
carottes non j'essaie de réduire ma
consommation de viande je suivais cad
bon un peu plus son truc de pique nique
avant j'en peux plus j'ai jemma lowe
votre esprit mais
j'ai peur 13la quand une porte se ferme
une autre s'ouvre toujours oui parfois
dans la gueule au ciel
vous savez ce qu'on vit là
on est en train de se tricoter des
souvenirs
ce comics
vous êtes magnifique
magassouba laisser partir tout seul il
espère il est violent
vous inquiétez pas il va revenir dans
exactement cinq secondes
[Musique]